wir schauen einmal auf die bilder heute
morgen 11 uhr in aachen dort machte sich
armin laschet in begleitung seiner frau
susanne auf den weg zur urne wir sehen
ihn hier als ein wahlzettel in der hand
wartet noch kurz ab damit auch die
kameras diesem moment einfangen können
und was sie nie kamera star kreuzchen
richtig gesetzt die gute nachricht für
seine parteikollegen aber man sieht eben
was er weht und die wahl wie wir alle
wissen muss geheim sein er hat seinen
stimmzettel falsch herum gefaltet und
deswegen wurde es für alle welt sichtbar
wo armin laschet heute bilder kann mal
passieren oder riesen panne von armin
laschet ja ich meine dadurch bricht
jetzt keinen atomkrieg aus oder oder
auch kein anderer krieg gott sei dank
aber man fragt sich was passiert da
eigentlich noch also der mann ist ja ist
ja ich hab das jetzt tatsächlich als sie
reinkam cs gab es natürlich gelesen aber
zum ersten mal live oder oder die
aufzeichnung gesehen er macht das was
politiker tun nimmt den wahlzettel und
hält ihn als sieg und damit die
fotografen allen foto haben länger in
die kamera und spätestens da fällt einem
doch auch obst da ist was falsch also
ein spitzenpolitiker hat natürlich immer
auch augen vorne hinten links und rechts
und es ist besser gestern im gestern
vergisst einer das trinkgeld zu geben
der lacher bei der flutkatastrophe wert
der bundespräsident wird da kommt es
kommt immer eine erklärung hinterher
und irgendwann denkt man sich mensch ist
der nicht von beratern umgeben oder
sieht er das nicht man fragt sich
wirklich was da passiert nicht ich
musste zunächst mal sagen darf ich das
zweimal danke bild muss ich wirklich
sagen gestern die trinkgeld affäre heute
die stimmzettel affäre wäre ohne euch
nicht an die öffentlichkeit gekommen und
mein eindruck ist also in welchem
begriff benutzt man für armin laschet es
gibt ja den letzten tagen einen den man
besser nicht benutzt ich nenne ihnen
jetzt mal freundlich tollpatsch einwahl
tollpatsch das darf natürlich einen
kanzlerkandidaten niemals passieren ich
hatte aber den eindruck wenn man sieht
wie er das eingeworfen hat dass er das
vielleicht sogar wollte dass das
fotografiert wird unser frau er
interessanterweise auch ihr rad lassen
hat dass er das am nächsten tag der das
bild in den zeitungen ist zweimal cdu
angekreuzt armin laschet und das ist
natürlich ein ding ich meine dass der
stimmzettel ist die wahl wird aber nicht
ungültig da durch die wahlhelfer um
enorm müssen das gesehen haben sie
hätten ihn in den arm fallen müssen und
den zettel wieder aus dem verkehr ziehen
hätten neun bekommen den er dann aber
hat er ja nicht der ist jetzt in der
urne drin also möglicherweise mit
absicht ist interessant weil die sind ja
auch selber geknickt also ist man muss
ja dann bewusst andersrum knicken um
dann den wahlzettel ebenso mit der cdu
stimmen nach außen sowie was hier bei
armin laschet sehen in die wahlurne zu
werfen andererseits gab serie im vorfeld
julian schon andere irritationen im
wahllokal erst mal war es gerammelt voll
und das nicht nur wegen der kameras die
dort drin waren es war einfach viele
menschen zu dem zeitpunkt mit armin
laschet im wahllokal und dann gab es bei
seiner ehefrau ja schon ein paar
irritationen also offenbar hatte sie
briefwahl beantragt und musste dann noch
mal neue unterlagen und so das lief
alles nicht so richtig geschmeidig und
dann das wie erklärst du dir das in auch
in der an der serie von pannen ein
wahlkampf ja man hätte über gedacht dass
es bei einer wahl einen moment gut
organisiert ist nämlich die wahl aber
dem war offenbar nicht so armin laschet
hat ja mal gesagt ich bin vielleicht
nicht der meister der inszenierung aber
ihr könnt euch alle drauf verlassen ich
bin armin laschet das hat er hier mal
wieder bewiesen es kursiert übrigens
auch schon der erste witz über diese
über diese kleine panne und der lautet
was haben armin laschet und bayerische
schulen gemeinsam das kreuz das für alle
sichtbar was mich aber primär was mich
noch eher was ich noch interessanter
fand ich habe mir jetzt extra meinen
zettel mitgebracht ich weiß nicht ob man
sie kameras einfangen kann also wenn wir
jetzt unsere ich war jetzt mal nur eine
reihe nach ja hier steht jetzt cdu so da
hat armin laschet ja sein kreuz gemacht
und das interessante ist ich mache es
mal so vor er hat nicht etwa wie wir
einfach ein kreuz so gemacht sondern hat
so gemacht
er wollte ganz ganz ganz sicher jedes
wie vor niemand daran also das nicht
entweder jemand das kreuz wieder weg weg
ist so zu sagen oder dass man es halt
genau sieht also wenn man nicht das auf
dem wasser drauf gucken wenn man sich
das noch mal anschaut er hat ein
schickes kreide es ist ja es ist ein
ganz dickes kreuz sollte schon ganz klar
sein was ja shit gewertet dass eben
nicht genau am 1 nicht einmal angekreuzt
aus dem stift so wie man es
normalerweise macht uns insofern auch
die these möglich armin laschet wollte
einfach noch mal zeigen oder bild ja
wann wo die leute anzukreuzen hermann
binkert in unser gespräch dazu er ist
chef des umfrageinstituts insa und uns
jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten tag
herr wickert
sie sehen wir diskutieren hier heißt
darüber über diese panne heute morgen
von armin laschet was glauben sie wie
viele menschen wird diese panne
erreichen und zwar in der konsequenz
dass sie vielleicht sich doch noch mal
gedanken machen mitten in diesem kopf an
kopf rennen wo sie ihr kreuzchen setzen
also ich glaube die meisten haben ja
schon gewählt wenn sie das mitbekommen
was da stattfindet die diskussion die
sie jetzt hat es eine spannende war das
fahrlässig oder was vorsatz ich denke
eines fonds hat zwar ist es rechtlich
noch mal eine ganz andere geschichte die
da passiert es erfüllt so ein stück bei
dem klischee was man hat naja wenn er
lasse etwas macht dann gibt es hier und
dort und ein problem kann auch sein dass
es in liebenswürdig macht ich glaube
nicht dass das auf den wahlausgang noch
große auswirkungen hat aber ich bin
diese frage vorsatz ganz spannend
also wenn das wollen wir hier weiter in
der runde diskutieren mit den soli
jörges und béla anda also inwieweit kann
das auf der zielgeraden noch diese wahl
tatsächlich beeinflussen negativ für
amila ist es schön dass umfrage forscher
immer ganz neutral sind deswegen ist ja
interessant auch der hinweis dass das
liebenswürdig wirken kann bei armin
laschet
hat das einmal erklären wie er das meint
wirtschaftliche analyse also die uns
würdig wenn man mit vorsatz sein sollte
so seien seine kreuze sichtbar macht als
spitzenpolitiker der ja auch durch
einige wahlen und wahlkämpfe gegangen
ist ich weiß nicht ob das bei der
bevölkerung hat sich so ankommt aber ist
ein interessanter punkt würde mich mal
interessieren
man sollte das ding raus fischen aus der
wanne wenn ausgezählt wird wenn es die
der einzige wahlschein ist der so in
diese urne geworfen wurde wirklich
anders werden
zwei es in zwei der von dem keiner und
der v-leute würdigten ich würde sagen
das sind was die einzigen ball scheint
deutschland die so in die ohne gewähr
dass in dieser ohne die einzige würde
ich sie raus ziehen und in museum ins
haus der geschichte eines angesichts
dieser und anderer eine rolle und unter
einer glaskuppel stellen damit man die
ständig besichtigen kann und dann fragen
ist das nicht mehr sein schild ja ja bei
schneider steht der wahlschein des
gescheiterten kanzlers oder der
wahlschein des neuen kanzler sie sehen
als ich ihr konnte armin laschet in
unsere diskussionsrunde dich wirklich
mit so einer aktion punkten was glauben
sie was zeichnet das für ein bild sie
sagten gerade vielleicht wird das auf
den einen oder anderen sogar menschlich
vielleicht kann der armin laschet im
besten fall vielleicht bei der oder dem
anderen ein bisschen punkten sogar
also ich glaube auch jetzt auf diese
kurze zeit da punktet man nicht finden
und der punkt ist jetzt als tollpatsch
oder ist es vor setzen wenn es vorsatz
ist dann ist es etwas was eindeutig
negativ zu kotieren ist und das mit dem
liebenswürdig habe ich ja so gemacht
dass man was man sagen kann dass
schwächen jemanden auch liebenswert
machen können als wenn jemand sage ich
nur tollpatschig ist wirkt es anders als
man das vorsätzlich gemacht sie sehen
ihre zahlen schauen für was steht denn
armin laschet dort für was schätzen die
menschen ihnen da besonders
also armin laschet ist ein
kanzlerkandidat der nicht wirklich bei
den leuten ankommt als olaf scholz ist
deutlich populärer
politiker ranking bei uns engagiert
armin laschet immer zwischen frau
wissler und
frau weiden also das ist nicht unbedingt
besonders vorne
also insofern hat er da nicht in einen
bonus gehabt dass und dann die union hat
mit niemals kanzlerkandidat eher eine
bürde zu tragen der pink hat sagt das
jetzt so
gleichmütig dahin ja zwischen frau
wissler und frau war weil er sich so
viel damit beschäftigt das sind
natürlich muss man sagen absolut
verheerende werte im polit in einem
politiker ranking ja einen wahlkampf auf
den letzten plätzen des deutschen blutes
rankings zu verbringen bei frau wissler
würde ich sagen die so jung dabei die
kennt man vielleicht gar nicht
verweigern ist unbeliebt weil sie einer
weil sie einer rechtsextremen
parteivorsitz die den holocaust
relativiert und armin laschet befindet
sich da unten ja und das zeigt natürlich
auch wie brutal dieser wahlkampf für ihn
in gewisser weise gewesen ist denn das
ist ja was womit ich dann ja täglich auf
stehe ich stehe täglich auf und weiß
in einer der unbeliebtesten in diesem
land und ich muss irgendwie diese wahl
gewinnen sonst ist meine karriere vorbei
das ist die psychologie mit der jeden
tag raus konnte noch einmal ganz kurz
und die zum thema nur zum thema zahlen
weil er kann dich heute ist der einzige
tag an dem ich zum thema zahlen oder der
einzige moment mehr liefern kann als
unser lieber binkert von insa es haben
bisher ungefähr 250.000 menschen also
eine viertelmillion menschen auf bild.de
da können wir das sehr genau
nachvollziehen die geschichte über armin
laschet war patzak über angelastet weil
panne gelesen eine viertelmillion an so
weit würde ich sagen wenn man sich
anschaut dass ganz viele unentschlossen
sind zwischen fdp und cdu wer zwischen
lindner und laschet und es da vielleicht
so ein bisschen den ausschlag gibt wer
ist der modernere für für dieses land
wer ist der bessere manager und ich bin
eigentlich cdu und wollte lindner jetzt
doch hin und war kurz davor zu lasche
zurück zu schwenken einfacher sorge dass
die cdu schwach wird dann ist das ein
moment der durchaus auswirkungen haben
also ich kenne im eigenen umfeld drei
leute die geschwenkten bis zum letzten
moment bis heute vormittag der hatten
aber diese geschichte noch nicht gesehen
und die sind zurückgekehrt zu zu armin
laschet und haben das definitiv
ausdrücklich als mitleids stimme
bezeichnet laut stimmen sind genauso
viel wir so und das zählen wieso ist das
mich dass ich bin vorsichtig da
schon wenn das ein trend ist was heißt
das für heute abend aber das ist ja nun
selber reingefallen gedanken
[Musik]